people were demanding that I document
the process behind my wisdom tooth
removal so my wisdom teeth are as the
professionals would say [ __ ]
[ __ ] I don't Vlog trust me you don't
want to see this yeah maybe you do I'll
decide if people want to see it after I
actually do the thing
in post
bye chica
I love you
who never says it back okay so this is
going to be signing off the next time
you see me I'm going to be beautiful
that's what they're doing to me right
this is the nose job thing right yeah
[Music]
I remember
so what
oh God
um
oh my God
yeah you are
um
[Music]
wasn't
oh we got it we got it
yes hello everybody
might as well you're always loud I'm
sorry I I will just woke up and
dance
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
I'm so sorry
[Music]
how's your mouth feel
um
they put magic in the moments
[Music]
my works are awesome
I'm a little excitable at the moment is
this normal
that's what I was like
Tommy is so good
I was doing kids like the week before me
the fishing chips
[Music]
no a buffalo sandwich you had both
Bible
I love you honey I love you you are oh
thank you
we're gonna get you home though we're
gonna go see Chica and Henry but they're
gonna be happy to see you
um
[Music]
I am better I just came out from surgery
I got Amy for Amy is the best
surgery I could hear you from the
waiting room you could hear you talking
yeah oh no what did I say I couldn't
tell your voice just carries
thanks to everybody you did you did I
wanted to make sure
I think they knew they said you were
great and they appreciate you I
appreciate it
[Music]
to me
I think people have seen you cry before
we
changed so much
are you good if I start driving yeah
okay okay so uh the adventure is over
I've got a long healing process
my head doesn't feel lighter than I
thought it'd be but then let me keep the
teeth yeah I'll show you those where are
they I'll show you in the back I'm gonna
do a giveaway on my channel hey
[Music]
hello
don't drop your camera down if you need
a break
no I'm not perfecting you I know but
you're also a sleepy professional you're
not sleepy you keep falling asleep
okay we're on the road I'm gonna tell
you where we're going I'm feeling better
I'm less loopy my tongue is numb my lips
are numb my lips are numb
they're supposed to
just enough I I I paid for the extra
package listen I was number six and four
of the song YouTube
my tongue is
huge but listen you guys are not what I
said I love you and I'm so grateful for
what you've done in my life is just a
bunch of funny
douchebags all of you it's so funny
you didn't tweet
ah sucks I don't have much else to say
and I think I'm coming out of it so I'm
gonna sign up for now maybe I'll have an
addendum on this video when we get back
home but for now I'm gonna sign off
because this camera is heavy and I
probably shouldn't be talking as
messages
but it's just no I really am grateful
that you guys are dangerous
it is
[Music]
[Music]
this weekend are no spoilers this
weekend is a big important project it's
gonna be so cool
[Music]
so I will see you later if this is the
end of the video goodbye bye bye but if
it's not using a bit okay but if it is
smash it like button and this is why
William the bell and um switches
okay bye
all right so all the kids kitties get
out of here what you're about to see
contained graphic content they let me
keep my teeth I haven't seen them myself
I imagine let me see them so you see
them first
in all their Glory are they bloody anger
ghosts and then this might get you
demonetized oh my God
adorable
it's just a bunch of chunks no
no uh I'm sorry I didn't know I didn't
see them oh no
anyway Whoever likes this video the most
whoever Rings this Bell the hardest
reverse Massachusetts foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
I'm just gonna relax and then make sure
the pie video goes up and then I'm going
to adjust
fresh and take it easy and drink
milkshakes in the mashed potatoes okay
love you guys and I love you Amy and
thank everybody at home
brother fist you